[Musik]
neuer tag neuer blog heute ist eine
eigenes reicher tag eigentlich passiert
gar nichts
und ich hab heute quasi gar nichts zu
tun müssen pakete abholen und das war's
deswegen führt heute fordern und europe
online mit julia
nanu wer taucht denn da plötzlich im
hintergrund vor dem spiegel auf die
leute die große arbeit erledigen würden
vor allem vorbereiten deswegen haben wir
uns wieder das erste mal zusammen vor
weil bevor allerdings irgendwas wollte
im block passiert mache ich mir erst mal
weg ist wie perfekt habe ich bitte diese
spiegeleier hingekriegt
ein seltenes phänomen freundes regel mal
wieder unter freunden eine heftige
baustelle neuerdings wie er in den
letzten blocks gesehen habe war ich
halte ich die letzten zehn tage oder so
bei meiner familie zu hause gar nicht
mitbekommen ist hier sollte euch helfen
hallo kannst du mir mal antworten oder
du da oben vielleicht wir holen jetzt
ein paar pakete ab wir sind paket
abholen von beziehungsweise drei pakete
dann mir wurde ein beamer zugeschickten
neuer monitor und fitnessprodukte leider
trotzdem locken
hier ein fertiges paket freunde hier
hinten ein fenster geht und jule musste
sogar hinten sitzen inzwischen
angefreundet möchte den leuten den block
gegen was sagen das sind in der tat
viele fitnessprodukte die mir
zugeschickt wurden ein beamer und hier
wurde da noch einen gaming monitor
ungeschickt war mir das allerdings
zugeschickt wurde erfahrt ihr die tage
der instagram story bitte folgt mehr auf
in fensterrahmen da kommste luca dotti
snacks mitgeliefert allerdings kommen
wir nun meine damen und herren juli
läuft schon in den richtigen raum da
hinten wir haben nun zu fordern halten
mit jule du hast dem aus
mein gott im auge gerade bist du schon
aufgeregt das ist die beste spielerin
deswegen weil die anderen alle zittern
werden
auch auf dem handy kann ich das gut
finden da steht also 2
warum zerstörst du ja wo sollen dort
jetzt den müll schmeißen auf den fußball
da kannst du jetzt irgendwo hier den ort
auswählen und kannst du mit der linken
maustaste darauf zurück wo du hin möchte
ist es ist richtig beschissen zurück mal
weh dann fliegen sie ein bisschen
schneller das hängst wenn ich hab das
wirst du heute erster also ich würde bis
jetzt hier kann einem haus jetzt so
genau genauso schlägst du das kaputt
dass ich war sehr gut jetzt hast du da
unten munition liegen
juli du kannst die türöffner mit dem du
musst nicht kaputtmachen sehr gut
wir brauchen erstmal ne waffe fast
ersten liebsten so wie du es dir
erwartet vorgestellt haben bis zum
schleifen lassen aber kannst du mir der
schleife binden du dir jetzt mal einen
typen irgendwo hier vorne suchte man
schießt bei den typen da vorne hat genau
so wie gott was sie getroffen muss ich
hin
warum landest du auf einem baum und war
hier wird das bleiben was ich
garantieren
du hast nur noch 38 leben warum du bist
kein baum gefahren
mit dem tool bauen nein 2000 jahre
später
sag mal hast du eben ziel der fed
gefühlt sehen ja oder nein ich muss doch
weglaufen vor dem möchte jetzt in das
labyrinth möchtest du dir da jetzt mal
versuchen delight hat darüber oder du
machst einfach die hecke kaputt machen
[Musik]
hier laufen
das war doch recht
also ich oder du bist mittlerweile schon
so weit dass du weißt wo du runter
springen muss beziehungsweise video die
web eröffnet da willst du hin
das ist kleiner knirps vielleicht ja
jetzt wie es hier mal dass an mit der
maus genauen jetzt wie drückt und jetzt
mit dem kopf in etwa auf die
markierungen genau dann würdest du genau
dort ankommen
was soll das muss nicht unterstützen
habe ich durch gar nicht du brauchst gar
nicht den kopf zu schütteln
warum bist du jetzt hier gelandet viele
menschen war und du möchtest du nicht
alle töten ihr müsst wissen
juli kennt fortnight also du hast es
aber sonst immer nur ab und an auf dem
handy gespielt
ach so ja jude war immer die längste in
der luft war auch mal den eiswagen ab
jetzt kleine kinder kein eis mehr
bekommt neue juli das deine erste
pistole drückte und jetzt nochmal genau
jetzt hast du mit pistole wenn jetzt auf
die 23 das klappt sehr gut
jetzt können auch keine kleinen kinder
mehr auf toilette gehen ich krieg die
krise wird dir wir müssen eine runde
machen wo du erster wir ist alles gut
ist ein unterhaltsames video schaut ihr
euch die zone weg ist du hast gewonnen
ja wahrscheinlich heißt es gewonnen
haben ja nur du bist jetzt herzlich
du bist in china jetzt ja so leute wie
man ihn inzwischen sich wohl ganz
einfach wer mit vier gewonnen
hier könnte ich eigentlich machen also
erst mal vorab gratulation zu ihrem sieg
was war ihrer meinung nach die
ausschlaggebende taktik für den sieg das
ist ja schön und freuen uns auch zu
hören wenn sie haben ja auch schon so
ein sticker aber ihnen daraufhin was
steht da drauf epischer sieger die man
allerdings auch schon erkennen kann sie
haben nach ihrem sieg jetzt ja auch
schon einige typen rumgekriegt denken
sie die mögen sie aufgrund ihres
charakters oder aufgrund ihrer
formidablen fordert leistungen
was würden sie den neuen unerfahrenen
fordert spieler mit auf den weg geben
die nicht direkt den ersten platz
[Musik]
denn von crafter fühlen sie dem motto
[Gelächter]
bedanke mich für das interview haben sie
noch was zu sagen
bei uns zwar nicht allerdings zum
fitnessstudio weil jude wurde gestern
ein probetraining macht mit meinem team
und die wollten ihr dann direkt einen
vertrag an training jetzt haben wir ja
heute das gespräch und versuchen dass
julia vielleicht nicht angewandt wird
jula die jetzt zu vertragen
juli abgeschlossen juli das volk halt
ich friere so doll ganz viele sachen für
einen tollen bad hallo zurück zu hause
angekommen ich habe mir ein anderes
t-shirt angezogen youtube ich eigentlich
youtuber schuldigen sind die youtuber
ich habe tatsächlich wer hätte gedacht
zwar wieder hunger und deswegen
bestellmöglichkeit wiener schnitzel
freunde auf mega dass der fotoreporter
einfach auf der tüte unterschrieben hat
so danke dafür
ich habe mir gerade so eine pfandflasche
gegeben dass sie die da hinten zu den
anderen antut und habe sich auf den
boden geschmissen damals ich will
wirklich dieser hinsicht hätten wir mal
die beiden anderen an der stelle wo
heute im block ist allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren julias es
euch gefallen wie judith fordert
gespielt haben wir sofort nicht
dominiert hat das gerne mal einen like
da freunde
wollt ihr dass jude eventuell auch mal
minecraft spielt
[Musik]